right now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week and we
begin with a surprising and concerning
rise in colon cancer death rates among
younger Americans a new research letter
published by the American Medical
Association examined mortality rates for
those aged 20 to 50 for the major
finding from 2004 to 2014 the colon
cancer death rate for white Americans
increased by around 14 percent or
roughly a 1.4 percent annual increase
statistics on African Americans actually
showed a decline here to discuss the
research is CBS News contributor dr.
Tara Narula tere are there signs
symptoms that people should keep in mind
here this is very important for people
to understand this is a very common
cancer it's the third leading cause of
cancer death in women the second leading
cause of cancer death in men estimated
that it will take about 50,000 lives
this year so while many times it can
remain asymptomatic there are things
that you can look for for example if you
notice any bright red blood in your
stool or change in the stool where it's
a little bit darker you have change in
your bowel habits so either diarrhea or
constipation belly pain unusual fatigue
weakness or loss of appetite and then
anemia sometimes that's the only sign a
low blood count or anemia that will pick
up that something is wrong
now there are certain conditions that
can predispose you genetically if you
have a strong family history if you have
other hereditary conditions or genetic
conditions and then inflammatory bowel
disease like Crohn's are all sort of
colitis but most important to remember
is that there are lifestyle risk factors
things that you can do yourself that can
prevent or help to reduce your risk so
for example diabetes out heavy alcohol
use smoking people who eat a diet that's
high in red or processed meat who don't
exercise as much who are overweight or
obese
all of those things will increase your
risk of developing course as Dana
mentioned the rate actually declined
among African Americans so do we know I
this affects some groups more than
others we don't really but certainly
there are or seem to be differences
racially and ethnically one of the
theories that has come about is this
idea that the microbiome may have an
effect so the microbiome what is it it's
the trillions of bacteria that live in
our gut over a thousand species and that
somehow through our changes in diet
exposures were altering our microbiome
and that this may be affecting us in
differential ways so that certain
ethnicities or races have different
micro biomes and certain bacteria may
actually promote the development of
cancer but important to understand from
the study we talked about
african-americans in general they are
actually at highest risk of developing
colon cancer highest risk of dying from
colon cancer they develop cancer a
little bit differently tends to be more
right-sided it could be at younger ages
more aggressive so actually the American
College of gastroenterology recommends
that african-americans consider being
screened as early as 45 our next topic
deals with another serious health issue
stroke according to the Centers for
Disease Control someone in the United
States suffers a stroke every 40 seconds
a new study found that while stroke
rates are going down for men that might
not be the case for women CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook
took a closer look in 2013 Diana
Hardiman was 30 years old a vegetarian a
nonsmoker
a surfer and the picture of health until
she had a stroke the paralysis ended up
seeping down from my arm to my leg
leaving the whole right side of my body
basically immobile I thought maybe I'm
becoming paralyzed or potentially seeing
death it was terrifying Hardiman is an
example of a puzzling and concerning
trend this week's report found from 1999
to 2005 the incidence of stroke declined
in both men and women but from 2005 to
2010 while the rates among men continued
to drop they stayed the same for women
dr. Katherine rexrode of Brigham and
Women's Hospital says risk factors for
stroke
such as obesity high blood pressure an
irregular heartbeat and diabetes may for
some reason affect women differently
than men
diabetes is a strong risk factor for
stroke in both men and women but in
women the risk is 26% higher than in men
with died
Hardiman recovered and went back to her
gourmet ice-cream business in Brooklyn
but last June she had a second stroke I
had to stop being CEO of my ice cream
business and start being CEO of my
health and put that as my priority which
I did this time doctors found the cause
a small hole in her heart and repaired
it when I was told that I had a stroke
I've always associated it with the
elderly something that your grandmother
has but never thought it would be
something that would happen to me I
think a lot of people would feel that
way it's surprising to read that
according to the CDC stroke kills twice
as many women as breast cancer is that
correct this is something that needs to
be on every woman's radar and I don't
think it is as a cardiologist we talk
about it a lot and women are really
unaware that this is the third leading
cause of death for women one out of five
women will have a stroke in their
lifetime and more women than men are
affected by stroke and as you saw you
know it is debilitating when you
suddenly cannot see cannot walk cannot
move part of your body can't speak
this is life-altering and so we're just
starting to really understand more about
this in 2014 is when the first
guidelines are really published about
women and Stroke and we learned that
there are risk factors that kind of tend
to affect women more than men that are
more prevalent in women for example
hypertension a big risk factor for
stroke
in addition things like migraine with
aura depression and anxiety and stress
more prevalent in women then there are
sex specific risk factors like pregnancy
gestational diabetes preeclampsia oral
contraceptive use as well as hormone
replacement therapy again all of these
raising the risk of stroke so really
important for women to not only
recognize the risk but realize that 80%
of strokes are preventable by looking at
their lifestyle and so in improving
things like exercise diet not smoking
monitoring blood pressure checking their
cholesterol monitoring blood sugar so
there's a lot we can do as women to
prevent this totally unaware of that I
mean I was associated more with men than
women I'm just stunned by those numbers
all right finally the ongoing battle
against antibiotic resistant bacteria
research published by the national
academy of
show the development of a test that
helps doctors better treat your
infection in the test only takes around
a half hour to produce a result so this
is really great right so you go to the
doctor you have a urine infection for
example and the doctor says well I'm not
sure if this antibiotic is really gonna
work for you but I'm gonna give it to
you anyway and so usually the tests to
see if your particular bacteria is
resistant or sensitive takes about one
to two days this would shorten that time
to about ten to thirty minutes so while
you're in the office they can test your
urine for example you can do it right
there right away
and then tell you here's the perfect
antibiotic that is perfect for the
bacteria you have and it avoids in the
bigger picture the creation of
antibiotic resistance which is what
happens when you give what we call
big-gun antibiotics that kill tons of
bacteria but you don't really need for
the infection exactly dr. taryn aruna
thank you